euh on va parler de l'affaire du petit
Émile puisque là il y a des nouveaux
éléments encore de l'affaire du petit
Émile on va rappeler à nos
téléspectateurs cette affaire qui nous
passionne tous malheureusement et il a
disparu depuis depuis maintenant
longtemps le le petit éil juillet Michel
pardonis le 8 juillet ouais 8 juillet ou
oui oui Emile a disparu depuis le 8
juillet de ce petit hameau du du haut
vernis et donc quasiment depuis 4 mois
les gendares
partent un peu dans tous les sens ont
fait un certain nombre d'actes de de de
police judiciaire il y a eu des
perquisitions au tout départ ils ont
cassé une dalle en béton
euh ils ont ciblé un jeune adolescent de
de 16 ans euh
il a priori ils arrivent pas à démontrer
grand-chose le concernant puisque euh on
lui reprochait en réalité de rouler trop
vite avec sa moto avec son quad avec son
tracteur on lui reprochait également
d'avoir cassé le le le mur enfin abîmé
le mur du grand-père euh il y a eu de
jours entiers de
perquisition dans des bâtiments qu'il
auxquels il a accès et qu'il dans
lesquels il habitent lui et sa famille
et ils n'ont pour l'instant de ce
côté-là rien trouvé et là donc très
récemment puisque c'était mardi alors
justement il y a du nouveau dans
l'enquête mardi il y a de nouveaux
éléments euh apparemment euh puisqu'ils
ont effectué une trentaine de
perquisitions dans un petit village
comme ça une trentaine de perquisitions
c'est le tout V c'est tout le village
non alors il y a 36 perquisitions en
tout mais c'est pas uniquement dans le
village c'est sur six départements en
réalité ils se sont comment pourquoi
comment ils ont choisi les les alors ils
ont ils partent de du bornage
téléphonique c'est-à-dire que il y a des
systèmes qui permettent de savoir qui se
trouvait avec son téléphone portable euh
au auvernet ou aux alentours du auvernet
euh le le 8 juillet à l'heure
approximative où cet enfant a disparu
donc les gendarmes ont récupéré le
listing de tous les propriétaires de
téléphone qui étaient dans le dans le
secteur et à partir de là ils ont cibler
alors là c'est peut-être un peu des
secrets de de de leur de leur Popot si
je puis dire ils en ont sélectionné
36 et parmi ces 36 il y a le grand-père
ah le fameux grand-père dont on a aussi
beaucoup parlé et il a eu une double
perquisition lui une à la maison où
l'enfant a disparu donc au vernis et
également à son domicile qui est à la
bouilladise dans les Bouches du
rô les autres perquisitions sont passées
dans les Bouches du Rône dans les Alpes
Maritimes dans la Loire en région
parisienne et également dans l'ouest de
la France et les gendarmes en ont
profité pour récupérer les téléphones
portables les ordinateurs les tablettes
parce que le le listing téléphonique ça
apporte des éléments mais quand on a
l'appareil on peut quand enfin il y a
des services spécialisés pour
ça retrouver des communications
téléphoniques ou retrouver plutôt des
contenu de SMS de messages de WhatsApp
et autres alors donc voilà ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est durant cette journée de mardi
vous allez voir alors ils ont
perquisitionn également chez le fameux
témoin ce un des deux témoins qui dit
qu'il a vu Émile descendre vers le
lavoir donc sa maison a été
perquisitionnée en fait c'est tout tous
les gens qui sont susceptibles d'avoir
été en contact direct ou indirect avec
le petit Émile la journée du 8 juillet
ils ont fait une cartographie
géolocalisation carte des lieux ils
pensent que c'est un hclos Le Vernet ou
le ha Vernet donc ils ont ciblé tous ces
gens-là et dans certaines maisons ils
ont passé le fameux Blu star c'est le
produit chimique qui permet de voir s'il
y a des taches de sang donc ils ont mené
des analyses complètes dans ces 36
maisons il bah il pense très
probablement pour le moment on n pas les
résultats il pense très probablement
qui s'est passé quelque chose autour de
ces 36 personnes résidence principale
résidence secondaire ils ont tout fait
alors c'est biz parce qu'il y a beaucoup
Deon qui tourne aussi autour on va
parler des grands-parents vouliz dire
quelque chose àan oui je voulais dire
d'une part il y a une rumeur qui dit que
cette cette vaste opération avait pour
but en réalité de perquisitionner chez
les grands-parents pour que ça passe
noyer dans le dans
inér parce que c'est vrai que les
journalistes et j'en fais partie lorsqu
les gendarmes ciblent un suspect
potentiel ça défè on l'a vu avec le avec
le jeune agriculteur de 16 ans donc là
je pense qu'il voulait et on peut
s'étonner qu'il l'IT pas fait plus tôt
d'ailleurs parce que 4 mois après c'est
quand même un petit peu tard mais
peut-être que c'est pas trop tard je
l'espère en tout
cas donc voilà il y a cette rumeur et on
peut s'étonner aussi également qu'il
n'it pas fouillé les maisons qui qui
était inoccupé parce que là ils se
concentrés sur les maisons qui étaient
occupé habité au moment de la
disparition mais qui dit que ces maisons
des des d'autres habitants n'y avaient
pas accès parce qu'ils avaient les clés
pour arroser les plantes pour faire je
sais pas quoi donc à la limite sur un
petit village comme le havernais c'était
peut-être pas très compliqué de
perquisitionner toutes les maisons
oui mais quand même c'est vrai que c'est
pourquoi il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disent que ça tourne autour des des
grands-parents oui le c'est bon
personnalité du grand-père ça pose
question mais on va pas ou mais
justement c'est le P pauvre grand-père
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
aussi qui disent pour l'instant ah bien
sûr il y a rien non mais il y a pas il y
a pas de garde à vue il y a même pas de
souon directement c'est bien de le
signaler parce que il y a beaucoup de
gens qui disent oui le grand-père le
grand-père grand-père comme ils ont ils
ont perquisitionné les grandsparents s
sa personnalité vous vous souvenez de
l'altercation qu' avait eu avec ce jeune
agriculteur là dont on avait parlé donc
voilà il pose question mais on ne peut
absolument pas aller plus loin pour le
moment alors parce qu'on se rappelle
qu'il y avait des rumeurs sur le
grand-père dès le début de l'affaire qui
serait très stricte selon beaucoup
d'habitants donc c'est pour ça aussi que
ça ça ça jase un peu là-bas oui oui non
je voulais dire que la perquisition chez
les grands-parents c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait normal euh dans l'affaire
grégoryie ça avait été le problème à
l'époque on avait pas fait de
perquisition chez les parents de de
Grégory donc Jean-Marie et Christine
villmain et ça a été reproché ensuite
parce que une perquisition c'est aussi
fermer une porte quand on trouve rien et
mettre les gens hors de hors de cause
hors de hors de champ or le grand les
grand grand pararents ils ne pouvait pas
éviter une perquisition parce qu'ils
sont les derniers à avoir vu cet enfant
et donc on peut se poser légitimement la
question et donc il faut
vérifierou ils espèrent aussi il y a la
la la thèse qu'en fait ils font des
perquisitions larges pour cibler une
maison il y a aussi l'autre thèse qui
est que ils font des perquisitions pour
agiter un un H clos un lieu clos qui
pour le moment ne bouge pas en espérant
que les gens réagissent parlent au
téléphone et ils vont les écouter
le problème le problème du téléphone on
est pas souvent d'accord euh le problème
du téléphone globalement on l' quand
même le problème du téléphone c'est que
si c'est un crime de prédateur c'est un
crime de solitaire et les par définition
ils vont pas parler au téléphone parce
que ils sont seuls à à avoir agi et à av
voir à savoir ce qu'ils ont fait voilà
bon alors donc ça en tout cas est-ce
qu'on a encore espoir de retrouver Émile
vivant je est-ce que les enquêteurs ont
encore espoir de retrouver Émile
vivant honnêtement non ah ça va oh
honnêtement non enfin on peut espérer
qu'il a été enlev et qui soit dans une
famille c'est une hypothèse
évidemment mais c'est un enfant de 2 ans
et demi enfin
c'est je souhaiterais qu'on le retrouve
nous aussi bien sûr merci Michel d'avoir
été avec nous merci à tous tout de suite
il y a que la vérité qui compte sur ces
8 inédit
inédit